[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight more drama
from the ongoing saga of Peter struck
and Lisa page tonight newly released
text messages from the two of them
messages that make it pretty obvious
that some of our most trusted officials
people who hold sensitive posts in this
country's most powerful law-enforcement
agency have radically abused their power
and hurt American citizens in the
process all for political reasons it's a
big story the new text messages were
revealed in a letter sent by congressman
Mark meadows to the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein the texts were
sent in April of 2017 they were part of
a batch that you'll remember had
supposedly been lost to some sort of
technical glitch
well now mysteriously and thankfully we
have them here's what they say on April
10th the struck told page that he wanted
to discuss a quote media leaking
strategy with her the very next day The
Washington Post reported the Obama
administration had spied on Trump
campaign advisor Carter page because
there was credible reason to believe
that page was an agent of Russia we now
know that's ridiculous
Carter page is no more a secret Russian
agent than you are
he's a former naval officer and
Annapolis graduate but at the time
thanks in part to struck and page in the
propaganda efforts the slander was taken
deadly seriously the story helped
destroy Carter pages life but struck in
Page weren't finished on April 12 struck
told Lisa page that two more articles
were coming out about her quote namesake
that's an obvious reference to Carter
page then on April 22nd struck texted
this quote article is out exclamation
point
well done page well so far that's the
extent of what we know from this latest
tranche of text but it tells us a lot it
is now beyond doubt that executive
branch employees worked to hurt the
president they worked for for political
reasons this is a betrayal of
constitutional order and of democracy
itself why because the president is
elected his employees in the executive
branch are not all of their power
derives from him and his power derives
from you the voters when they subvert
him they're subverting you that's what
the Constitution says
it's also clear by the way there is rot
at the highest levels of American law
enforcement we place tremendous trust in
the FBI because they hold tremendous
power over all of us some of them it
turns out are abusing that power to spy
on us and then leak information about it
to the press destroying people in the
process as the worst kind of abuse of
power the left defends it why